donc on travaille avec le secteur public
les mairies les conseils généraux on en
a pas mal
et aussi le secteur privé les grandes
entreprises à l'école connecté au futur
de l'industrie de montigny le bretonneux
la formation est en apprentissage un
mois et demi en école un mois et demi en
entreprise
le cfi appartient à la chambre des
commerce industrie paris donc
cet organisme qui est d'état donc c'est
dans des écoles publiques et gratuites
en tout les entreprises sont référencés
au niveau des sion des commerces
industries donc de ce fait on a des
quatre personnes dédiées qui ne font que
ça qui voudraient une entreprise partir
du moment où les gens font recruter
admis on met en place un parcours
d'accompagnement donc ça va du cv et de
la lettre de motivation en allant
jusqu'à l'entretien embauche on leur
donne en conclusion tous les outils et
les méthodes nécessaires pour mener au
mieux leur recherche de leur entreprise
d'accueil
le cf qui forment des apprentis du bac
pro jusqu'au master et propose des
études en informatique en électronique
et en robotique
l'objectif derrière ce serait d'intégrer
une entreprise en rapport avec la
formation de coûts dans la conception
robotique mois après derrière j'ai le
projet aussi de faire ma propre micro
entreprise d'événementiel nos étudiants
de travailler dans un projet qui est à
la réducation des bras après les arrêter
dans la filière robotique une
cinquantaine d'étudiants travaillent sur
la programmation sur la conception il
intègre le site en bac + 2 et bac + 3 on
travaille soit soit robotique ont pas la
robotique c'est un sujet très basse donc
soit ça la robotique industrielle donc
ne pas plutôt rambo bras soit on parle
de la robotique d'assistance avec un
autre établissement situé sur henry
l'école connecté au futur de l'industrie
accueille 800 étudiants